Hmm.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn his time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
January 1st,
2018 oh my God.
It's a new year with the new year comes
hopes in jeans for a better world and
God wants us to sit there and try
to make it a better world. Well,
you should probably start with yourself,
friends.
Have you seen those people late at night
trying to tell you how to make it a
better world?
You know,
or somebody writes a song about it,
make it a better place for you,
ed,
for me and up plumber down the street.
Right?
It's very difficult. The older you get
to listen to those songs going like,
all right,
so
not only are you not going to
make the world a better place,
you're going to write some cheese ball
fucking song and make money off the fact
that people want to
make it a better place.
You're going to give some fucking
stupid pop culture psychology,
right? Pop Psychology. Is that
what you're going to throw it?
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It's like after nine 11 when that
country guy wrote that song, you know,
Uncle Sam's Buda, Buda, Buda, and you're
right. It's like, how did he like,
like that wasn't going to be a giant hit,
you know?
I Dunno what I'm talking about.
All I could tell you is I'm doing this
Monday morning podcast on Tuesday, uh,
because I was like, well,
what do I do? Do I do it?
Do I do it the night before
I go to the Rose Bowl?
And then by the time I tell you the
Rosebowl stories, it's like four days old,
or do I just go to the rose
bowl and do it a little late?
I decided on the ladder.
All right.
And I apologize to any, I
dunno, whatever fucking group,
you know what I'm hoping
in 20 2018 happens,
I just hope that people start
standing up to all of this fucking,
you know,
the amount of people being offended.
Okay.
You know,
it's not that you didn't get offended.
It's the level of coverage that it gets
compared to shit that really is way,
way, way more devastating to
our lives. By the way, you know,
it's really was bugging me.
Okay.
You know, and there was all
those hurricanes and everybody,
everybody sending fucking money
out and all alleged shit. Right?
Got To help all these people in Houston.
Got To help all these people in Florida.
Hey, where the fuck were you guys when
the Hollywood hills were on fire? Ha,
I didn't see any fucking benefits.
Tore fucking,
what's his name? Ralph Nader for
so fucking guys name owns Fox,
whatever the fuck his name is with our
poor bastards mansion was catching on
fire. Did any you fucking
people floating on a mattress?
A Houston a few months ago,
a rubber couple of nickels
together and send it to him.
Make some teary eyed videos.
I just kind of seems like
it's a one way street here.
The fuck is the guy's name alone.
Spock's
is it Ralph? It's one of those fucking
names where you see like, you know,
you know chicks didn't take him seriously
in high school and then all of a
sudden he owns like the biggest
network ever and all those women are,
I should've fucked Ralph.
Why did I have to fuck to the quarterback?
Baker mere fucking Mansfield,
whatever the fuck his name is.
The guy won the Heisman,
the hell's his name.
Baker Mayfield. Boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom. Sorry. That was
my bed. Curtis Mayfield one.
Apollo pass to that guy was, huh? If I
could sing and all these great songs,
he's doing a Goddamn gig and
that literally the lighting
falls down on them and
breaks his fucking neck.
I mean, how did it,
and he continued to write music.
I don't know how the fuck it's at. Some
people, I don't know. I hate to say this,
I know this about myself at that
ever fucking happened to me.
I would just be yelling, kill me to
everybody who came walking into the room.
We're going to start your
rehab. Kill me, kill me.
Gimme a fucking something.
I'm not strong enough to get through this.
Jesus. This is dark. Sorry, whatever.
That's what happens when you just
fucking start running your gap.
All of a sudden this happens.
Okay,
so I'd like to apologize to all Curtis
Mayfield fence in anybody's stubbed their
toe.
Speaking of which,
I'm at the fucking I co I cooked
up a goddamn storm this weekend.
I went out strong.
All right,
so the Great Jay law have Rosebowl
tailgate legend Jason Law head.
He fucking uh, he goes to put together
the menu, right? And he does, doesn't go,
we're doing burgers, we're doing dogs.
He just, he doesn't do that horse shit.
J fucking analyze like bill Bellacheck,
he fucking looks okay.
Oklahoma is playing George's playing.
So the next thing you know, he's like,
well, in Oklahoma, you know, they
do this tri tip something or other.
So he gets that going. I tell them, hey,
you are may make a pie this year goes,
yeah, why don't you make
a peach Pie for Georgia?
And He ties this whole fucking Oklahoma
Georgia thing together was incredible.
So I had never made a peach pie, right.
And I know peaches or out of season.
So I'm like,
why am not going to go down there and
buy some fucking out of season peach to
some poor fucking had to pick off of
what used to be his own property down in
Costa Rica, whatever the fuck they do,
however they do the fruit nowadays.
I fucking, I said, I said, fuck it man.
I'll go down and get them canned peaches.
I'm going to get some God canned peaches.
So I got some canned peaches.
Yeah,
pick the fucking recipe off the Internet.
This is what I found with
recipes on the Internet. Okay.
They're going to get it to you so it
tastes really good, but they're not gonna.
They're not gonna give you the
recipe. We're, it tastes great.
So what they're going to do, is it
going to, you don't remember that guy.
I'm going to bring it up a notch. Bam.
And he'd be screaming and yelling.
He had that fucking band.
Okay.
Emeril Lagasse, right? Remember
how you said take it up a notch?
Don't they do on the Internet
is every fucking recipe.
They take it down a notch
to take it down a notch.
And then they fucking remove something.
Okay.
They take something out, some
little specials, special spice.
So anytime you make an a fucking pie,
it's a little sage advice fee. All right?
It's going to be the usual. Okay. If
you're doing some sort of fruit there,
it's going to be basically
a quarter cup of sugar.
I mean quarter cup of flour
and like a cup of sugar.
And then there's going to be cinnamon,
Nutmeg, uh, possibly vanilla,
I dunno, some sort of bullshit. And
then going to see 80 to teeth when we,
the eighth is like a teaspoon
of that. Fuck that. Fuck that.
All right.
They say eighth of a teaspoon taking
nice helping of it with the eighth of a
teaspoon. That's what I do. I throw
that shit in there. What do you want?
A teaspoon?
I'll give you a teaspoon and a quarter.
Maybe a teaspoon and a half
if I'm feeling crazy. Right.
You just kind of bring the levels
up on everything and then you think,
what else would they have on their,
you know, they probably, you know,
squeeze a little lime on the peaches,
you know,
before they fucking do all of this shit,
right?
Maybe a little vanilla in there and then
you always got to throw like, you know,
a little bit of butter in there
to mix all of that shit together.
Then you taste it. You throw a little more
sugar on top, you bring everything up.
That's what I did. And
uh, I gotta tell you, man,
I got rave reviews on a peach
pie. Who Knew? Who Knew?
Okay.
You know, people, you know, if you don't
try to explore the limits of your talents,
you'll never truly find out
how great your life could be.
So I made a peach pie.
I made a practice one with Nia and it
was a deal I didn't have a lot of times.
So I actually went to the
store and bought a store,
bought frozen pies on the bottom,
sec religious,
and then I made a homemade one for on top,
you know,
cut my work in half.
And then there was just all this weirdness
where the one on the bottom was kinda
dumb, but the one on top
wasn't. So I took it out and uh,
you Nia took one bite of it and just goes
[inaudible] [inaudible] does that shit.
And I knew she was right, but I also
got mad at her, you know what I mean?
Cause I'm lazy.
I didn't want to go back.
So I fucking egg wash the God damn
pie because I forgot to do that.
Sprinkled some sugar on it,
threw it back in,
then it was better and
I mean a decent pie.
But then I brought all the levels up
and the one that I did to the rose bowl
fucking crushed
or maybe people would just be a nice,
I don't know. Um, I also
made a quiche Lorraine.
I've always wanted to make a quiche.
I mean, who doesn't like eggs?
Who does it like Pie Emmy right there.
You got both things going on.
This is breakfast and dessert
all at the same fucking time.
And uh,
I go to make this thing and of course
knee is all over me looking at this,
looking at that, look at it. This,
I fucking stick to Keishon there,
right?
Do the whole damn thing.
I fucking 45 minutes in. You know, I
give it a little poke with the tongs.
It still looks Jello is hell.
So I leave it in for another 10 minutes
and then it looks pretty much solid and
I'm getting nervous dot. I'm going to burn
it. So I take it out, I let it cool off.
Couple of hours later I cut into it.
It looks a little runny,
but I'm too hungry so I don't give a shit.
So I'm eating and it's clearly needs
to go back in the oven for 10 minutes,
but it's fucking delicious. So
I get, I got near to try this.
I think it needs to be,
you know,
I think it needs to go back to
the oven maybe for 10 minutes.
And she just cuts it and she goes,
Ooh.
And then eats it and goes
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
I just went, you know what?
Fuck you. And she's like, what? I'm just
being honest. I'm like, I know. Okay.
I know I just want it, but it still
tastes good, right? She goes, yeah,
but it's running. His shit needs
to go back in the oven. I'm like,
we could've said it tasted good first
and she stormed out of the room and then
I was like, oh, come on honey. Come on.
Sorry.
I won't be like this in 2018
so I put it back in the oven for like
another 10 minutes. Actually Nia did.
She finished the thing off and
it takes the fucking delicious.
And then before the fucking
rose bowl the night before,
I'm thinking,
all right,
la ahead is going to be making his
classic fucking a breakfast sandwich,
which is basically a English muffin.
He puts a little Habari cheese on one
side and then he has his avocado spread.
He does on the other side.
Then he cooks this fucking egg
to absolute perfection. Okay.
Or it's not too runny. It's not
overhardt, it's just perfect.
Not quite over meat. Uh, medium.
It sounded like a medium rare.
So when you bite into it,
the egg yolk oozes out,
but it doesn't fall out of the
sandwich and all of that shit. Right.
And then also he,
he had marinated this,
this tri tip that he put on top of
that and it was the best fucking eggs.
It was such a good egg sandwich.
I only had one cause he goes,
you want to have another one? It's
like, no, I don't want to kill it.
You know what I mean?
And the night before I had made
these hash browns, you know,
the thing about it is, is you don't
want to make the fucking things,
but she also don't want the
things to turn all brown and Shit.
So I actually did the whole mix and
then put it in a fucking Ziploc bag in
squished all the air out of it.
I possibly could stuck it in
the fridge and it was fine.
I cooked those fuckers up on the side
at that point I was a little shit face.
I think I overdid it.
That's right.
I was already drunk before
breakfast even came out.
All right.
We had already loaded up the truck.
We put the game changer in there.
The game changer. Who
by the way? All right.
The game changer is a is a flat
top grill with four burners.
All right, and the propane
gas, I'm telling you right.
That's what the fuck you
want to bring to a cookout
that think it's just, you never have
to worry about your fire going out.
There's not like, there's not all of
this pressure. There's none of that shit.
He just turned that fucking thing on.
Jay's just like a short order cook.
I've never done last two years,
I've never seen him so relaxed at
a cookout because before you know,
we had a Hibachi that's way down here.
We had another one that was up
on its legs. This guy is going,
he's doing like fucking 400 squats
and hour trying to cook everything,
making sure his fire doesn't
go out time and shit. And um,
and he cooks the whole time.
It's not like he's cooking one thing.
He cooks up breakfast and he
cooks something in the middle.
Then he cooks the dinner. So he was
always having to add shit and Kohl's.
And all that means is over the
course of like six hours. Um,
so the flat top grill that j
law had dubbed the game changer.
Um,
he was just crushing it all day and um,
yeah,
I got gotten these things
because this was our 10th um,
bowl in a row in anybody who's married
knows that your 10 year thing is 10 and
not only do they know that the, you
know, 10 the 10 anniversary, you,
there's no way you can go out and buy
something made out of tin for your wife
only and she's going to be happy with
that unless you met an absolute sweetheart
who doesn't mind being broke or it
doesn't mind that she married a cheek.
Fuck one of the other.
Anyways,
so I went out and I got these flasks
made up for me and Barton it cause we,
we were the original guys. It was just the
two, just the two of us the first year.
So I got a giant Roman numeral 10,
like the Superbowl engraved on the front
and on the back I just had Joe Barton,
Nick Rose Bowl, tailgate legend. And
then I did like the American Express,
the member sense and had oh nine and um,
next year law had gets his in a two years.
Feminists gets his,
although I have to correct you cause I
already had a made up and I thought that
they both came in 2010. Um, anyways,
so I'm out there throwing
the football around.
I got some booze in me.
Right.
I smoked a little weed,
which I never do,
but I'm just trying to
lay off the bows and uh,
this is why I don't smoke
weed is because you know,
with booze, if you reach for a
bottle of vodka, you know, okay.
You know basically what the punch
to the face it's going to be.
Or if you grab a beer, you know what
that's going to be. You grab some wine,
you know what that's going
to be when someone goes, hey,
you want to take a hit of this choice?
You don't know what the fuck it is.
Is that the, is it that shit that just
kinda makes you feel like, hey man,
like everything's gonna be alright man.
Or is it going to have you just
fucking staring at a God damn tree?
Okay.
So I, you know, I dunno. What,
what are you supposed to do?
Just take one hit and then stand there
and wait for your face to start melting
and be like, oh, well it didn't. This
is why I'm done with fucking weed too.
So I take a fucking hit. I
don't feel anything. I'm like,
oh, this must be the, the,
the light ones. So then I
go back, ended about two,
three times and next thing you know, I'm
telling everybody at the Tailgate, I go,
hey man, listen, I know I'm really high
right now, but look at that fucking tree.
Isn't it? Fucking, that
tree is fucking a mess.
Like some shit out of a horror movie.
Book it down.
Look at the way it's like bent like that,
and they're just laughing at me and I am
so at peace that I don't care that I'm
actually, I don't give a fuck
that they're laughing at me.
I'm just happy at that point.
Then it bringing them joy is I
make a complete fool of myself.
Um,
and I'm drinking from the flask
and then Jay throws a burger on.
We've got this grass fed fucking
grass fed fucking me dude.
I fucking, it might've been
the best burger I ever had,
but also I was so high, I was just
talking to people about this fucking tree,
which felt like an intense
minute. So, you know, it was like,
at least probably what,
like 11 minutes.
Okay.
I ate that Burger. It was
fucking amazing. And uh,
then I went over to a chair. I sat down
and I passed out for like two hours.
Jay was making these fucking
meatball subs on a Brioche Bun.
And I completely, I the last
like four or five years in a row,
I have missed the main course.
And by the way,
Americans call it an [inaudible], call it
a main course, don't call it the entree.
All Alright?
In French entree means to enter it.
That's actually the beginning of the meal
and somewhere across the fucking ocean
in the scurvy and the fucking
slavery and the indentured servitude,
however, whatever distracted
us, we fucked that up.
Entree means to enter.
That's the beginning. Okay.
So just say the main course and for
the main core cell had this, uh,
what do you have for entrees?
Um,
so I miss that.
I woke up and uh,
I ended up, I tried the pie with the
Allah mode. It was fucking delicious.
Everybody loved it.
And at that point I was kind of fucking
sober because I was actually way more
high than I was shit faced.
And um,
okay.
I didn't even smoke a
cigar and I went into the,
I went into the game
and, uh, I just started,
anytime a vendor came by
just started crushing waters,
I was already on the wagon. That's how
fucked up I got at the tailgate. Like,
you know,
like when you're still legally drunk and
you're already back on the what you're
telling people,
I'm on the wagon as you have,
like literally they could
let your breath on fire. Um,
that's, that's when, you
know, you went too hard.
I don't really have any fucking stories
about the tailgate cause I barely
remember it. Um, other than
it was fucking awesome.
I do remember I was drinking, uh, Ma, uh,
Miller's, I was drinking out of that
flask. I had, you know, once a year,
uh, mill, I had Miller and Miller lite.
Miller lite comes back with their old
school, less filling tastes great bottle.
Okay.
So I had a couple of those.
Um,
I threw the football around lefty.
I vaguely remember that. Oh.
And then somebody at the tailgate told
me a fucking story about how Garappolo
ended up on the fucking 40.
Niners.
Evidently the Cleveland browns
were interested in getting him,
but bill Bellacheck still holds a grudge
against him for him, for his time,
you know, 1995 when he was coaching at
which I believe he was also with fucking,
what's his face?
Nick Saban there.
Yeah.
So he's like, fuck that. And
he calls up the 49. He goes,
give me a second round draft pick. We'll
give you a grappler. How fucking nuts is.
Uh, I've heard a couple of
those stories recently. Like,
do you know the Celtics got into a
position to get to, to get Bill Russell?
This is his story that was told to me.
I sit down,
gather around and listened to this tale.
Um,
the Celtics had too good of a year to
be in a position to draft Bill Russell.
So red our back makes a bunch of fucking
moves to get all the way up to number
two. Alright. But the problem is,
is the Rochester royals is
some shit head number one.
There was nothing he could do
to get them to not, you know,
to give up the number one pick and
everybody was going to take Bill Russell.
He was just clearly the best guy.
So the Boston guy
had the fucking ice capades every year
and they used to make a bunch of money
off that.
Now I know a lot of you
fucking millennials out there
like the ice capades bunch
of people twirling around, dress
on the ice, right? Skating around,
dressed like fucking Yogi and booboo bear.
Why the fuck would I go see that bullshit?
Well,
it was before the Internet is the one
you had a little black and white fucking
TV. You know what I mean? The
picture was always jumping.
This was just some exciting shit.
There wasn't a Teddy Barr or fucking free
Internet porn. Every once in a while,
you know, once a year, these beautiful
fucking goddess women would come in
with their shapely thighs and he could
sit there and look at them and pretend
you were into the yard and he
just sat right next to your wife.
You could fucking, you know, look
at some games over there, right?
So what it would always sell out.
So the Rochester royals
were hurting for money.
So red our back called up the
ice capade guy. He goes, Hey,
can you do me a fucking solid?
Can you fucking get the ice?
Capades can you guarantee that you'll
do a couple of dates out there for these
fucking guys? He said, absolutely I will.
So he called them up as a list. Listen,
I'll get you to give
me the number one pick.
I'll give you the fucking
ice capades for a week.
You make all this God damn money.
And the miser that owned the team said,
you know what, I'll take
that deal. I will say,
forget Bill Russell.
So Dorothy Hamill can come in,
or Peggy Fleming,
whoever the fuck it was back there.
I Dunno.
Way back then.
It was probably some woman named Ethel
and she was considered hot, right?
Bethel McGuire. And Hazel said,
Gorski her come and skate.
Oh my God. Have you ever
shit so fucking hot. Right.
Years later they wrote
on the golden girls,
but back then they were
all hot piece of ass.
I know I skipped over a
lot of fucking details,
so you should probably listen to
the bill Simmons podcast, right.
To figure out what really happened.
But that's what was told to me.
And you know what, God
dammit, I'm sticking with it.
I'm fucking sticking with that story.
So anyways, all Billie, no fun.
I'm not going a bunch of days
again, but like, I'm just like, uh,
I'm done.
All right.
I came off the wagon on December 26th
and now it's January 2nd and I'm right
back on. I had, I had a hell of a week.
One day I didn't drink. All
right. That was the 28th.
December 20th. So six out of
the last seven days I drank. Uh,
I don't like how I feel.
I don't like how I look.
I just can't fucking do it anymore.
Okay. I'm turning 50 in June.
I had a great half of a century run.
All right.
I never really drank until I was like 17.
So what am I had a good 30 years.
I'm gonna Larry Bird. Speaking of
the guard, I had a nice 33 year run.
Okay.
So, uh, I am now going to be
that guy that picks a spot.
Am I going to be that fucking dude?
Maybe I'll just be that guy that has a
glass of wine with dinner every once in a
while.
You know,
it's just like,
just all this awkward silence between me
and my wife is we sit on either end of
this really long dinner table,
you know,
and all you hear is just me like turning
the pages of the paper and you know,
shaking it, you know, you do that
thing to make sure it straightens out.
Okay.
Every once in a while
just being like hone.
Who did you see down in
Brazil in a resilient?
Um, I dunno what I'm going to do, but, uh,
I, I'm just, I'm, I'm bringing the way I
was bringing everything up in that recipe.
I'm bringing everything down,
bringing everything down.
All right.
I'm fucking, uh, back to crush in the
waters. I'm back on my diet and, uh,
I got a couple of goals this year.
All right?
On the biggest mistakes I made in my
adult life was buying 34 inch jeans after
being a 32. All right. 32
best shape of my fucking life.
They started getting a little tight around
the fucking waste and I thought, oh,
you know, you get all the, you fill out
and it's like, no bill, you put on weight,
you can't, why don't you just take
fucking seven to 10 days to lose?
I didn't, I bought the
next size up jeans. Okay.
And that was stupid because that just
gave me this leeway to be a fat fuck.
Who feels comfortable in his pants?
You never buy the next size up jeans
after you'd done growing and all of that
shit. You know what I mean? Unless you're
a fucking beanpole, which may be, I was,
so I'm back down to 33 I
figure I'll stay there.
So that's what I'm going to do. I got
to like my fucking wardrobe right now.
I've got,
it's just like,
okay,
you know, I hate going
shopping. All right.
And I have not bought a fucking shirt,
a shirt or a pair of pants
in a couple of years.
Kind of fucking a couple
of free tee shirts.
I bought a prime his t shirt at the
concert I went to. But other than that,
it is just, I just, you know,
and I got rid of a bunch of old clothes,
so I have like,
I have two shirts that I wear,
one of two shirts when I fucking headline.
Those are my two headlining shirts and
I think I have a pullover sweater and
that's it.
And,
uh,
I don't think I give a shit,
you know,
I got to go out there,
have some
fucking rhinestone shiny goddamn shirt.
Yeah.
I really believe that as long as I have
a fucking act that nobody's going to
read really paying attention to the shirt.
Right? Well, now that I brought it up,
you've got to,
uh,
I dunno. Maybe I'll buy Shannon. Maybe
I'll buy a fucking sweat. You know,
I'm thinking, I'm thinking I'm gonna be
that guy that just dresses all in black.
If I wasn't so fucking pasty
and I wouldn't look like
a floating head in hands,
I would do that.
But what's great about a black shirt,
you can wear that like three days in a
row before anybody really even notices
like, this motherfucker's not
changing his shirt. You know,
that is the genius of
Malcolm young rest his soul,
the greatest rhythm guitarist and
rock and roll history, in my opinion.
MMM.
The genius of the way
that that meant dressed.
The sheer amount of money that that
man saved by just wearing jeans and a
fucking tee shirt,
right?
Einstein that said Einstein Shit.
That's what genius is.
Do they get rid of all the white noise
and they just focus on what's fucking
important?
Others.
What he did ages was his eyeline,
his pants and a shirt.
I'm not going to be fucking sitting
there trying to be in style.
I'm going to dress timeless blue jeans
and a fucking black tee shirt and I'm
done. Do you ever see the
let there be rock video?
That's one of my favorite parts of the
video when he's getting ready for the
show and he takes the t shirt off and
then he snaps his fingers like he's a
spoiled rockstar and they just
throw him another tee shirt,
the exact same color he puts it on or a
slightly different color and then that's
it.
It's over.
MMM.
Anyways, my shoulder's been
doing great and then I fucked
it up at the, at the, uh,
the tailgate. By the way. I was throwing
left handed doing our right, you know,
making sure I was giving my right
shoulder arrest and everything.
I hadn't felt any pain in my
shoulder for days. Long story short,
the end of the end of the, uh,
the tailgate, we're going to,
to a close up the table and,
uh,
I'm on one side with the other guys on
the other side and we're folding up the
legs and the one was getting
stubborn and where I had my fingers,
it fucking slammed down on
both of my fingers, right?
Just wham. And I went, ah, fuck.
And I pulled my arms out, you know,
I was basically reaching around
the fucking table, you know,
like I was given the skinniest person
ever the finish who had that finishing
move in wrestling where they just put
you in a fucking bear hug and they would
act like he was being crushed to death.
I was doing that with the table.
So when I went to Yank my arms
out really quickly, it was like,
it was like I was throwing two elbows
at the same time and felt like fucking
lightning in my right shoulder. And, uh,
I think I went right back to square one.
I Dunno what the fuck I got.
Do I think I'm going to do that Coby shit?
Um,
Robin told me about that whole stem
cell shit and I just get scared of that
stuff.
I Dunno the way Joe Rogan is fearless
and we'll read up on something and then
make an informed decision before
he takes a step in that direction.
I just hear about something new.
Do not read up on it and act like an
old lady who thinks the fucking sky's
falling. That's the way I approach
life. So I haven't done that yet.
My shoulders still fucked up.
Um,
I might do that thing
where they take your own.
What I like about that fucking spin in a,
your blood is it's your own blood and
then they shoot it back in. Right.
Although I would want to watch
them the whole time, you know,
follow them around with my own blood
to make sure they don't take like the
fucking blood of a yak or a fucking
chimp or some shit, whatever they,
whatever the fuck they would,
whatever they do when these days, um,
to try and get that thing fixed.
Um, all right, let me, uh,
let me reach,
read to what do I have any advertising?
Um, I dunno that I do during
the holidays it slows down.
Okay.
I don't have any advertising.
Well, what do you know?
What do Ya know? All right,
let me see here. I guess I
don't have any advertising.
Well fuck it. Let's
continue talking. All right,
this is what else I did on my wonderful
over my wonderful holiday break.
I went down to the comedy store,
did his set, had a great time
and I was driving home, you know,
and I'm driving along sunset just starting
to fucking listen to my tunes and all
of a sudden I go by this venue
and I look at what do I see?
I see Dave Chappelle and
John Mayer or doing a show.
I'm like, get the fuck Outta here. Right?
So I call up a buddy of mine that books
all the shows and I said, hey, what's,
what's the story with this?
This John Mayer.
Okay.
You know,
come out with his band.
Okay,
you know this Dave going first is John, go
on first, Blah Blah Blah. And he's like,
no. What happens is John comes out, plays
like four songs. He brings Dave out.
Dave does stand up
okay
for an hour,
an hour and a half.
And then he brings John back out
and then they just sort of riff.
Okay.
Is Dave talks about shit, John will play
the music underneath. And I was like,
I got to fucking see that.
So uh,
me and my me and the lovely Nia,
we went down there cause I never take
her out on New Year's Eve because that is
the original St Patrick's Day. Um, plus
I go to the rose bowl the next day,
so I need to get my sleep before I get
absolutely hammered and passed out in the
fucking chair for a couple
hours. Missing meatball sub. Um,
so we went down there and um,
just had such a great fucking night. And
um, I don't think I've ever seen that.
I don't think I've ever seen two
people that fucking talented.
Like there's usually one genius and then
surrounded by a bunch of people who are
just sitting there.
Isn't he amazing?
I'm so happy to be playing bass with this
genius or I'm so happy to be fucking,
I don't know,
whatever the fuck else.
I'm so happy to be in the ice capades
with this twirling genius. Right.
It was two of them and when I kind of
noticed about both of them is that they
just saw like most genius minds take
day [inaudible] they get rid of all the
fucking white noise.
Everything about every bit that
Chappelle did was just like,
there was no fat on it.
And he got right to the fucking point.
Another thing that I loved was,
uh,
I can't believe that I've been in this
business long enough that we're like the
older guys now.
It always blows my mind then I'm like
five years older than Dave Chappelle cause
he was already a made guy when I came in.
So I always look at him like he's
got 10 years on me, you know,
or 15 and you know, just when
I watch his act, I'm like,
this guy's clearly been doing this a
good couple of decades longer than me.
And the reality is,
I think he's only been doing it
like six years longer than I have.
It's something like that.
He's fucking amazing.
And what I love too is
just, he's that same. Um,
with all that's changed,
everybody getting offended,
all of this fucking crap by you get
in trouble. He hasn't changed at all.
He's just like that same guy that I saw
way back in the day when I used to go to
the Boston Comedy Club in watch him go
on at like two in the morning and just
start murdering at two
in the fucking morning.
And I remember by just always sit there
going, how to find, or you do that,
how do you get that funny at two in the
morning in front of a crowd that gave up
on the show like an hour ago and they're
tired and they just want to go home
that second he steps on
stage. Boom. He just like,
he just starts fucking killing. So, um,
you know, days up to him murdering me
and Nia, I like just fucking laughing,
dying and having a great time and I'm,
and then he brings John Mayer back on.
I don't want to ruin the show for him
cause I don't know how many they're going
to do. But, uh,
basically if Dave was up there and
he would just say in like, you know,
I was watching fucking
Hawaii five o like John,
whatever she fucking rifts.
It's clearly that David's just ripping,
like mayor can play
whatever the fuck he said.
And Dave said that at one point he goes,
I don't know if you
guys realize this shit,
but John Mayer can play whatever he hears.
And then he just started
doing all this crazy shit,
like make it as guitar sound
like a cat or a car beeping.
Like it went beyond.
I can play songs,
like he could just do
noises around the house,
but it was fucking,
there was fucking incredible.
Um, so if you get a chance,
I don't know, you know,
if you get a chance to go see the show,
definitely, uh, definitely go do it.
Um, all right. And what that, let me, uh,
speaking of which, let me promote this,
um,
uh,
the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit and I
forgot to fucking ass Dave Chappelle if
he ever wanted to come in and do it.
God dammit.
Anyways.
All right.
Patrice O'Neal benefit
is on February 20th,
2018, uh, it makes a great gift
for Christmas. This is old copy.
Uh,
whatever.
It's a great fucking benefit.
Uh,
we have all these amazing
comedians on it and um,
what a great way to start the year by
seeing an all star lineup of old comedians
like myself,
all the way down to new comedians that
were influenced by Patrice O'Neal.
By the way. I'm going to post this video
and once a year I got a post. It, um,
is that one when, when Patrice
was watching the up and down game,
just his laugh and all of that shit.
I just got up once a year. I, I,
I kind of watched that
video once a year and um,
it's kind of a nice, over the years where
it became less sad for me to watch it.
And now it just, uh, I don't
know. I get it. I just,
I guess I got to the point in my grief,
which I'll never be over him not
being around, but I guess, um,
I've gotten to the point with my grief
where I just, I just think like, um,
I like what an amazing
person to have known. Um,
ah, see, it's still sad. It's,
it's always going to be sad,
but can you doubt it's going to be
fucking set. So I'll, I'll post that.
But those who are new to the podcast,
you know, as the years go by,
maybe even new to Patrice, which
blows my mind, but, uh, uh,
I'll post that video and then
you can go down a wonderful,
hilarious rabbit hole of anything that
fucking guy ever said. So anyways,
we're doing a benefit for his loved ones
that he was taken care of when he was,
uh,
still alive and a,
all the money after we get done paying
for the fucking venue, being upfront,
being transparent, uh, we'll go
to his loved ones. All right.
It's on February 20th in New York City.
What a great excuse to
go to New York City.
Go skating down Rockefella center.
Watch a bunch of great comedians on
are the greatest comic that I ever saw.
A Patrice O'Neil. February 20th, 2018
at the New York City Center. Alright,
there we go. Um, moving on.
Uh, did anybody watch the Celtics versus
the Houston fucking rocket? Holy Shit.
God Damn.
What a fucking game that was James hard
by the way, is, is fun to fucking watch.
You know I love about tech guy.
He looks,
he doesn't look like a basketball player.
I look at that guy and I go,
that guy knows how to play the trumpet.
There's something about him doesn't he
looks like one of those fucking like his
last name should be Hargrove or
some shit. And this, I dunno,
something about his shorts, his
beard and his haircut. It's very,
he looks Aba ish even though I
guess he should have a giant Afro.
I don't know what, but I taped
the game. I heard how amazing was,
I already knew the result and I watched
the game and of course my fucking,
my uh,
my recording cut off right at the end of
the game before Al Horford hit the shot
and a hardened kind of had a
meltdown I guess through style.
Marcus smart to the floor or some shit.
I don't know what happened,
but I guess he got pissed. He went a
little bronkowske against the bills.
Um, by the way, congratulations
to the buffalo bills.
I was actually really
pulling for you guys, um,
even though you were in our
division or whatever. Um,
I just feel like the football
gods had punished you guys enough.
It was great to see you guys back.
Get back in with tie Rod Taylor. Um,
so congratulations on that.
And then also can you believe the
fucking NFL season is already over?
How does that happen?
I'll tell you what else
I don't understand.
How it happens is I go to see that
unbelievable rose bowl game I just fucking
saw and I didn't even talk about the game.
All right,
here's my breakdown or the game.
Fucking
okay.
Fucking,
here we go.
You know this is going to be an
intelligence breakdown of the game.
Oklahoma's going no huddle.
The whole fucking first half,
George's Goddamn head is spinning around.
They don't know what to do.
Right before the half,
they kicked an onside kick,
which I get this six second
slap you thinking, all right,
I don't want this guy to run this ball
back. We'll kick it to an up person.
They'll, we'll fucking tackle them,
Yada, Yada, Yada. And that'll be over.
Who the fuck knew Georgia
was going to come out?
Throw a quick fucking pass getting field
goal range and instead of being down by
three scores,
17 points.
They're only down by two scores were like
dumb fucking move and George's getting
the Goddamn ball. All
right. No, no, I'm sorry.
Oklahoma got the ball. They kicked
off to them. That was the thing.
They were up by 17 fucking points and
they would get the ball after the half.
I mean, they had their foot on their
fucking neck. I get the onsite thing.
I don't fault fault them for that,
but in the third quarter
when they stopped going,
no huddle and they started playing Marty
ball and they're trying to bleed out
the fucking,
I actually get that fucking move,
but then Georgia scores a touchdown.
Now they've scored 10 on answered.
You still trying to bleed the clock.
They score another touchdown.
Now they've gone 17 on the
answer is still in your huddle.
They score 24 fucking unanswered points
to go up by seven before you finally
decide out of the fucking blue to go back
to no huddle.
And the second they go back to no huddle,
Georgia has a problem again. Bam.
They score a fucking touchdown.
I'm running out of sound effects
because thou we, they fumble the ball.
You return it.
Now you're up by fucking seven.
You just got to give it to
Georgia bulldogs. Them Georgia.
God Damn fucking bulldogs. Wait.
They came back, tied it up,
and for the first time ever in a hundred
and I don't know how many goddamn years
of the fucking Rosebowl all right.
They had an overtime game and it doesn't
just go to one over time it goes to
two,
two overtimes congratulations
to the Georgia bulldogs,
um, on an amazing victory.
Uh, I don't know why I was,
I was actually, even though I'm
a big SCC guy, I was kinda torn.
I was a little emotionally torn.
I was rooting for Oklahoma
for whatever fucking reason.
I just decided I was
going to root for them.
I don't have anything
against Georgia, but, um,
okay.
I was,
uh,
I was actually also on another level kind
of sight to see Georgia wind because j
law head is so fucking pissed
that Ohio state didn't get in.
And he thinks the SCC is
totally fucking overrated.
MMM.
And you know, he was arguing
for the PAC 12. He was our,
it at one point he was fucking
arguing. I was like, Jesus Christ Shea,
it's eight o'clock. You're already
fucking wine and a by the buckeyes.
And he said,
the most innocent voice every pointed at
somebody else at the tailgate. He goes,
he brought it up, he pointed, he went from
like going and we, and we fucking bomb.
We beat Penn state and they'll
say, he goes, he brought it up.
So I thought it was kind of funny,
you know, and then Alabama also one,
so both SCC teams,
sec teams that got in are now
going to play for the championship.
So the SEC is going to
win another fucking title.
And it just cracks me up that
that's going to bug j law head.
And he just will not admit that the Ohio
state buckeyes had no fucking business
last year of being one of the final four,
considering they lost to Penn state.
And then Penn state won
the title. He goes, Bill,
you're not listening to what I'm saying.
I'm saying that Penn State got screwed.
But that's all he'll say.
He will not say that Ohio state did
not deserve to be in their last year,
despite the fact that they then went
there and lost 24, seven and he's all,
all fucking Deshaun Watson was
unbelievable. It's like, dude,
he wasn't tackling guys too.
You scored no points.
So I feel like Ohio state this year,
God punished,
um,
for the fucking snooze fest.
They basically ate their balls last year.
They wanted to get another Saturday night,
eight o'clock spot at the club.
They like, no buddy, you're
going to get a Wednesday. Um,
and I actually think that Ohio state
would have done great, you know,
considering when I watched their game,
how their front for are all first and
second round draft picks on the defensive
side. Um, I actually agree with j law had,
but like you don't get
your cake and eat it.
You don't get to suck and get in and lose
by 24 points and don't even score one
fucking point the year before.
And then the next year when you're
actually good enough to get an also get
rewarded, you know? So that's my
beef. That's my beef with j law here,
but I still love the Getty death,
so we'll get over it. Um, anyways,
but amazing fucking game. And um, we,
we went the whole game without having
an incident until the very end.
I Dunno what happened.
[inaudible] nick was, you know,
a little boost up and I think he bumped
into somebody in front of us in this
fucking guy who I swear
to God was as old as me,
starts yelling at Barton Creek and Barton.
Nick is just staring at him and I'm
just staring at him and he's like,
got be a nice into you.
We just fucking stare at him and
I'm looking at this guy like, dude,
you're as old as me and you're yelling
at the human version of a fucking Kodiak
bear.
Okay.
And the guy didn't know what she was
waiting for us to respond and we didn't
respond to me was just lie ahead.
We were all just staring at the guy
and they just looks at Joanie goes,
fuck you.
Okay.
They fucking turns around.
It's like don't,
between all of us were
about 225 years old.
This is the first rose bowl ever.
Okay.
That is going into fucking over time.
You want to, you want to get kicked out.
Uh,
you want to roll around in the
stadium floors with your fucking,
this guy wasn't even
wearing true religion jeans,
which appeared for Come Dad James in the
last fucking 12 years. He's, he went,
I think he was, she was
probably wearing the, you know,
the lead jeans and on the tag it
just said giant bold letters. Lee,
you know, which, where I came from
basically meant the, you know,
your family was barely,
could barely afford to
live in a blue collar town.
Um, if he had the legions,
the legions in the gap gates,
you know, you had to have
Levi, you had to have lead.
That's how simple life was back then.
If he had Levi,
that meant that your parents
were actually doing well. Okay.
And it before, uh, diesel
jeans came in and fucked,
just fucked it all up.
You know,
jeans were like 25,
30 bucks.
And I know with inflation will just
say jeans for like 50 bucks, right?
Then all of a sudden diesel comes along
and they're like twice that and the next
thing you know,
there's like $200 pairs of jeans
that suffocate your balls and still
can't get up and over your flat ass.
I don't fucking understand
what I don't understand. Jeans.
And then that tapered in down the bottom.
Like you're going to do ballet and
people need to see your feet, right?
Like you're going to reenact
the thriller video. Um,
I dunno. Anyways, let's
read some of the fucking,
the letters here over the a that I got,
if I can find them. Oh, I guess I
didn't copy and paste some, did I?
Where are they? All right. Here we go.
This is a very dramatic email.
It says it's the name of
this email is good. Bye,
dear bill.
I'm sadly no longer a fan.
It's really too bad because I was a huge
fan. All right. What do you think I did?
What did I say? Who
did I say it about? Uh,
went to see you and Paul Versey in Albany,
New York. Oh, that was a great show.
And I've watched every one of your
specials as well as F is for family.
And I'm an avid podcast listener.
All right? So what he's doing now,
and he or she is doing is establishing
that they listened to every fucking thing
that I do. This is what everybody
does when they complain,
you can't just complain.
You have to establish credibility.
Like when people argue politics,
you know,
they sit there and they
go, Hey, I'm a democrat.
I'm for gay marriage of legalizing pot.
But this Obama has gone too far. All
right? Or the other way around. You know,
I'm fucking level blurb, but this Trump is
what everybody does. All right? He goes,
I'm not super religious.
Oh,
Gj you're not super religious.
But I obviously said something
about your God. All right,
but you took it too far when you trashed
Jesus and anyone who believes in him,
when the fuck did I do that through?
Do you understand that this is unscripted?
I don't remember half to
shit. I said today. I mean,
if you want to take it
seriously, by all means, he goes,
you take his shots here and there,
which is tolerable. But in the 1228,
17 replay portion of the podcast,
uh,
it was just too much. Oh, I
got to listen to that one.
I didn't hear it the first time.
And I wish whomever is picking the replays
and more of an inkling than to play
that expert excerpt.
As much as I wish you didn't say it.
Um, well, aren't you
glad that they played it?
So now you can know how bad a person I am.
A,
this probably won't matter to you
because at this point you don't need me
anymore.
Oh, come on. Come back in though.
Comedy Hut. That being said, I bet
promoter and a supporter for a long time.
This has to be a woman.
This they're just doing,
they're just going 100% guilt.
I'm sure you will never read this as you
probably have a screener at this point.
Uh, just taking a shot. I do
wish you continued success. Ah,
look at this. And they're still
going to go out as a class.
It's person's a class and nothing but
the best for you and the lovely Mia.
It's Nia with an end.
You know what? I'm a, I,
I'm saying goodbye to you the amount of
times that I said Nia on the podcast and
you still don't even know my wife's
name and you have the nerve to get upset
with me cause I trashed
the old Jay star there.
Why don't you like,
what would Jesus do?
Jesus would forgive me and continue
to listen to the podcast, wouldn't he?
I would think. Um, anyways, uh,
that being said or being above,
uh, uh, for the lovely mia
and your daughter in there,
uh, Boston sucks and go fuck yourself. Um,
ps checkout, Gary Newman's new
album, all synth, but really cool.
All right.
P S s if you don't read
this or if you do read this,
don't use a southern accent because
I'm from New York. Lol. You know what,
but you're going to be back.
I got a feeling you're going to be back.
Um,
I love these fucking people.
That is just like all
the dumb shit that I say.
I've trashed people that smoke weed.
I trashed women.
I trashed Jesus. I trash fucking
anybody who's a Republican.
Anybody who's a Democrat,
all of this fucking shit.
And everybody listens and listens and
listens and all of a sudden once it,
you know,
fucking comes into your world like I the
trash above ground pools and all of a
sudden I've got to listen
to somebody going, hi.
You know, Jess, because I can't afford
a dig a goddamn hole in my back yard.
You know,
look at that right there.
If offensive to southern people as if
there's people up north that can't afford
to fucking have a backhoe come in there
and whatever the fuck it is that they do,
right, dig into the Goddamn ground. Um,
eh. You know what I mean? All right.
See you draw the line of Jesus for,
there you go.
I mean,
as far as my limited understanding
of Jesus and what exactly it was,
he was trying to prove with all this
party tricks with the fish and the bread
over there. Um, I think he was
a very forgiving person, sir.
So I think if you're truly into the
teachings of Jesus and you're truly strong
enough spiritually,
you can handle one 20 minute fucking
clip from a God damn podcast from a few
fucking years ago. You know what the real
thing is here, sir, is you need to grow,
okay?
What I am saying is not
going to infiltrate into your
fucking soul and all of a
sudden make you possess and
have you kill your whole family.
Why can't you just look at me and Phil
felt sad for me that I'm going to go to
hell and that you're
going to go to heaven.
You're going to be on a
little puffy cloud. There is,
I'm burning forever, right?
Why don't you just look at it that way,
all right?
It's not that he's leaving.
It's that you know all
the dumb shit that I say,
all of the dumb shit that I fucking say.
And then that one thing,
you look past everything else,
all right? But whatever, you know,
more power to you. God bless you.
God bless you and your search.
I wish you well on your search to
a Jesus only positivity podcast.
All right? All right. Your journey to Aa.
Bear Dare Billy to Shift Drinking
Albino ginge dad bod once a solid C Cup.
Now a solid eight cups or moves
a lot and there's a mouthful.
All right.
Me and another friend of bill w agree
that you're qualifying story for AA is
unfolding perfectly. Uh,
right. Here we go. Um,
I'm an alcoholic,
so you must be an alcoholic.
All right, I'm going to lose this guy's
offense. I hate fucking gay people.
There's nothing more self-involved than
someone who has an addictive personality
and all they think is whatever happened
to them. Whatever they're going through,
you also have to be going through because
they are the center of the fucking
universe. All right? From your
off the wagon on the wagon,
off the wagon to your,
let's try some controlled drinking.
You are perfect. A material, uh,
can't wait to hear about your surrender
and your acknowledgement that you lack
and that lack of power is your
dilemma. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Stop projecting all of your shit.
You fucking loser.
I fucking hate people in Aa. I really do.
Not all of them, but people like this.
Listen Dude, just because you are under
the sink during your kid's birthday,
drinking fucking mouthwash.
Don't break my balls over a F.
I don't have to go to your
dumb ass fucking meeting.
I've gone to some AA meetings.
The stories you guys tell my
GI is on the fucking ground.
You guys make me look
like a fucking fairy. Uh,
he's in denial right now.
The Gag gag by dude.
I'm going to tell you
something that I just did.
I just went off the wagon for six days,
drank like an animal yesterday
and while I was drunk,
effortlessly said, you know, and I'm
not drinking anymore effortlessly.
I didn't have to surrender and say,
I have no power over this.
Bad,
bad.
I don't need to go down to your dumb
ass group and smoked cigarettes and he
donuts with all you guys down there
with the a blown out fucking wall.
Flower noses. All right, I'm fine.
Anyways. And your discovery that there
is a power greater than yourself,
one who can solve all your problems.
Yeah.
Or one that you can dump all your shit
on. It's a great life. You could even say,
even say it's a life second to none,
one day at a time. Easy. Does
it keep it simple? Stupid?
I just can't wait to hear you speak
from the podium delivering a message of
hope.
It's not the meetings you make.
It's the steps you take. Thankfully,
there are only 12 of them. Ah,
love your biggest 32 year
old blonde Nigerian fan.
Uh, Hey, God bless you and your
sobriety. But no, all right, whatever.
Uh,
uh,
this is how my sobriety works. I just like
how I feel when I'm sober from a tall,
I like how I look. I like the weight
that I become. It's total vanity.
There becomes a point in
your life where you're just,
you're just too fucking old to drink.
It just beats the shit out of you.
So, uh, thank you sir.
But I don't need to go down
there and surrender and you know,
I'm telling you right now,
if you think you're a fucking alcoholic,
go to a God damn a meeting. These
fucking people, I swear to God,
they'll tell stories where like,
like they're sitting there,
half their nose is hanging off
their face and that just go in like,
so I take some duct tape and I fucking
take my nose back onto my face and all
I'm thinking is I got to go back to the
liquor store and get more booze, man.
Okay.
When I got arrested for drinking and
driving about 30 fucking years ago,
um, I ever met why was required to
go to two AA meetings and I was like,
these people are out of their fucking,
and every story was that they would do.
And then I belted my wife in the face.
I actually hit my wife over
the head with our own child.
And the crazy thing is, is I would
say, can like, you know what?
I got to go get a drink
and I'll look,
I shouldn't be laughing at people that
have that much of a fucking problem. Okay.
But, um, I could tell you this, sir,
I don't need to surrender to anything.
All right?
I know that I,
there are times in my life when I drink
too much and I have the ability to look
at myself, say I have a problem,
and then fucking walk away from it.
MMM.
Okay.
That's it. All right.
And I want to tell you,
I want you to answer me name one of your
fucking Aa friends down there that can
come off the wagon and drank like I did.
You know the yesterday I
drank six out of seven days.
I had two drinks. One day I had a beer
the next day, didn't drink the next day,
had two drinks at the John
Mayer's Chappelle thing,
and then had two drinks the next day
and then fucking got hammered at,
at the Rose Bowl. And now I can
just be like, ah, I'd fuck that.
I'm not doing that now. That's
it. I can, I can do that, sir.
I'm sorry that you can't do that.
I'm sorry that you need to go down
there and put your arms around a budget.
They got to give you a little chip.
Every league, your little fucking cookie.
You know, God bless you. How many fucking
people might lose it on this podcast.
God bless you buddy. If that's
what the fuck you have to do. Um,
are you one of those alcoholics too
who's still a fucking cunt, you know,
and then blames everything on your
fucking disease. Oh, sorry bro.
I just get a lot of shit coming up.
You know,
you've got that built in fucking excuse.
Um,
anyways,
not saying they're all like that.
Cause I know a lot of cool people
that are in fucking a, but like, uh,
I really think that if you're,
if you're an alcoholic,
that when you're drinking your life
just like falls apart. It really does.
You know what I mean?
Um,
I mean I wake up,
hung over for flights and it sucks.
And I definitely am not a casual drinker.
I'm definitely a fucking binge drinker
and I know that I shouldn't be doing that
shit.
But if I actually had a real fucking job,
that's my biggest problem is
I don't have a fucking job.
So like I have to tell you like when,
you know, when I'm like really
fucking busy and I have shit to do,
I don't really drink. But the thing that
like right now it's fucking Tuesday,
it's nine in the morning.
I'm sitting here in my fucking pajamas
and I could just sit here for the rest of
the, for rest of the Goddamn week.
I don't have anything to do. I mean,
if I wasn't so fucking responsible,
patting myself on the back,
I mean there's a bunch of shit that I
could just put off to next week and in,
I could just sit here
drinking non fucking stop.
So that's the problem.
My problem is my fucking free time.
So, um, I'm gonna I respect the
fact that you're trying to help me.
Um, my wife, my wife on the hand, uh,
I've told her a bunch of times saying, I
am I an alcoholic. She goes, God, Bill,
you're not an alcoholic.
You're not a fucking alcoholic.
So I would think that she would know. She
lives with me, but I appreciate it. Um,
and all these going to say the whole
time is he's in denial. Elo, Willie,
the bug and the example. You know what
alcoholics are like, the like Madonna,
Madonna, we always just did over the top
shocking stuff. You know what I mean?
And then if you've been like Madonna,
that music video sucked and
then they get to hide behind.
We're all I was looking for was a
reaction. It's art. Art is just, you know,
you can't judge it and blub
know that fucking sakes.
So there you go. Um, I dunno.
Listen, I'm open to the idea.
If I am an alcoholic,
but there's no fucking way I'll
ever be able to go to a meeting.
There's no way I'm not going to go down
there and just not fucking laugh my
balls off. Listening to your, your,
your fucking stories that would make
Keith Richards go. Jesus Christ.
I know a guy that fucking, he
drank so much. He did a face plant.
He's fucking teeth.
One of his teeth fucking
went through his lower lip.
All right. Any woke up the
next day with his fucking lips,
look at like a Goddamn duck bill.
Any,
any g immediately grabbed the
fucking, you know, a 40 ouncer.
They put a stride so he could
keep drinking as the alcohol.
Most of it was going in his mouth.
Part of it was going through
the hole that was in his face.
Okay.
As much as my moral is, I am,
I'd be like, ah, you know what?
I'm going to take a fucking year off
at this point. You know, so whatever.
I sir,
I actually,
I think that there's different
degrees of abusing alcohol.
I definitely abuse it.
Admittedly,
I'm wrong and it's definitely gotten
not a control, but I'm like a habit guy.
Like if I'm working out,
I'm fucking working out like a maniac.
If I'm sitting around
and I'm eating bad food,
I eat bad food like a fucking maniac,
but not to the point of like
someone that has addiction.
Like I'll eat bad to the
point I put on 1520 pounds,
I don't have to be cut out of my house.
I don't balloon up a hundred fucking
pounds the way somebody who's addicted to
food would,
all right.
And I'll go out and I'll go
on a fucking booze binge.
It'd be like, I got to knock this
off. What the fuck am I doing?
I got to knock this off and
I'm just kind of able to do it.
And uh,
I feel like I have to apologize to
you that I'm able to do that. Sorry.
I mean look like I'm done right now.
I will have no problem going.
I Dunno.
As long as I fucking want to go,
you know,
it's not like I'm never going to have a
glass of wine with a great fucking meal
again. But, um, I dunno, whatever.
I appreciate your, uh, your concern. But,
um,
I am going to be sober now just out of
vanity because I got this new fucking
diet right.
And the Dean del Ray was telling me about.
And when I do that,
when I,
when I'm on his diet and if I just go
for a fucking walk around the block with
my lovely daughter,
I do that a couple times a day.
And I'm not drinking and I'm not
eating sugar or anything like that.
I barely have to work out and I,
and I,
the fucking, the, everything
just falls off you.
Um,
and it's the easiest way to stay in
shape and I fucking hate working out.
So,
um,
that's way more appealing to me then.
Um,
you know, as much fun as I had
over the last fucking week. I mean,
it's way more appealing at my age,
you know, and plus I got a kit,
you know, I got to have a kid and I can't
be like, fucking, I just can't do it.
I just can't do it. I can't have it
in my fucking life and that's it.
So I don't need to go down there and do
all of that bullshit. All right. I'm,
I'm a comedian. All right. I
don't like groups. All right,
lady.
Who's bad at arguing a
dear Billy backward balls,
backwards balls a, I'm actually
a 15 year old girl. Oh,
Jesus.
The fuck who the f Andrew,
you're trying to get me in trouble here.
Uh,
so I guess you couldn't say really
say that. I'm a lady. Oh my God,
this is already creeping me out yet. But
I love your podcast and listen to a 24,
seven because I feel like balanced needs,
oh,
balance needs to be restored to the world.
After all the females listening to
Dr Phil and loose women have gotten a
slightly fucked up view on things.
Uh,
I respect that you're not going to let
mainstream media have the only say on the
truth. In other words, what you're
saying is you like to hear my opinion.
I'm not always right, but you'll listen
to it. I appreciate that. All right.
My whole life, the 15 years
of my life, Jesus Christ,
there's shit in my house. Said for 15
years I've been meaning to get to it. Um,
your whole life is 15 years. That's
incredible. Uh, my whole life,
I've been bad at arguing either I say
the wrong thing at the wrong time or I
focus on the wrong point,
or I'm easily manipulated by guilt trips,
et cetera. Uh, whatever it is,
I can never get it right or
stand my ground. For example,
I have this one friend
who is literally three.
I was a little,
a little three year old on the inside.
I thought you said you were hanging
out with a three year old. I was like,
this is getting even more creepy.
Um,
I can't say shit to her without a crime.
Uh,
one time she wanted some of my food,
but I told her that I hadn't had
breakfast and couldn't share that day.
She said to me, you're be, you're so
mean. What the fuck is your problem?
What? Yeah, you got, you get
that person out of your life.
Okay.
I just gave her some food cause I hate
it when people think bad about me.
But inside I was like, bitch, what?
It took me like two hours to realize
that she didn't even think I was mean.
She just wanted the food and she knew
how to get it. Oh my God. You know,
something.
Your thought process that it took me
till I was 37 to realize that you're way
ahead of the curve here.
What's your realizing for the first time
in your life is that this people out
there that are not good people.
See. So what I did was I, I,
I went out into the world where you are
as a 15 year old and existed as that
person til about 37 before I actually
started to examine human behavior.
And um,
yeah,
so what,
where you are right now is when you
first start to realize that there's these
constant in life,
um,
what's going to happen is like two or
three days later or an hour later after
the moment, you're going
to be like, oh fuck yeah.
She said Blahblahblahblahblah and not
cause she meant that it's cause she just,
she wanted x, y, and z.
Well the more you do that,
the more you're going to be able to be
in the moment and you're going to catch
people in the moment. And then once
you're able to do it in real time,
people aren't going to be able to
fuck with me anymore. And then when,
and then the only thing you'll have
to learn how to do is the judgment.
Is this worth me?
You know,
applying this skill in real time.
Like yesterday that guy had turned
around and yelled, fuck you at Bart,
nick and all that. There was like
four of us wanting him overtime.
Rosebowl not even worth engaging.
We all just stared at him
and then he didn't know what
to do. He yelled, fuck you.
And then he turned around and he felt
good. He said, fuck you to four guys.
We didn't do anything. He feels good
and insecure around his wife, you know,
and nobody got kicked out.
Nobody had to fight or whatever.
And then there's other times when
you actually say something back.
So when he was, I'll read the
rest of this, but um, yeah.
Uh, right out of the gate,
you'd being too hard on yourself.
Right?
Most of the girls in my class
are pretty weak physically,
and it happens to be that as a girl,
I have unnaturally broad shoulders,
excuse the pun,
ah,
and weigh about two pounds
more than most of them.
The fact is hard to ignore when you're
staring at their faces while they giggle
behind their hands.
I have violent tendencies,
which I'm working on, but I know
I can beat the shit out of them.
And that makes it so much harder
to verbally verbally argue. Uh,
they are much better at it than me.
So even when I'm right,
I lose and I always end up
wanting to just uppercut,
sending an upper cut straight
to their fucking skull.
MMM.
Oh, whatever. All right.
I would love a few pointers as to what
to do in an argument and how to tell them
when I'm being manipulated before I start
latching onto the fucked up mind game.
MMM.
Of doing things. Some advice
would be great. Thanks a lot
and go fuck yourself. Ps,
me and my sister have a huge disagreement
because it's my personal opinion that
guys,
whoever,
girlfriend should still be able to go
to strip clubs and have a good time
without their girlfriend getting mad.
My sister says that for me to say that
I must have no respect for myself and
we'll end up with a
piece of Shit Guy Jesus.
Also to extreme opinions and my right,
or do I have some sort of self respect
issues that I'm not aware of yet?
All right,
let me comment on the first fucking thing.
All right?
Kids are mean. Kids bullied,
they gang up on you.
You never should resort to
physical violence, all right?
But what she got to do,
and she'd got to fight fire with fire.
So what you have to do, all right,
is nobody's perfect.
So you have to find that fucking thing,
all right?
You have to find that fucking thing,
And you just get them with that,
all right?
And then they,
they know it will hurt their feelings,
especially if they're good
looking popular people.
You can really fucking
get to them all right?
Like here's something that I do
that I learned to do after years
of arguing with people after my shows.
You know,
if somebody came up to me and was
like, Hey, let me tell you fe,
then Stephie sanded that way and you're
a fucking get gag. And as they yelled,
all of that, I used to try to argue
my points go, well, hey, you know,
it's just jokes. I also made
fun of people in that hurricane.
You didn't get offended by that.
You know what I learned to
do when someone was given,
when they were giving me
shit, I would just go, hey,
you got something between your teeth.
That's what I would say.
Even though they didn't. And then
they would be so fucking mortified,
they walk away and then they'd
be gone. Like you know, you know,
sucking on their teeth and shit and it's
just shit. Just shut them the fuck up.
So you need to find your version of that.
Okay?
So what I would do is I would
really study them all right?
And what you gotta do is you just got to
find something that's wrong with them.
Maybe their ear lobes are too big. And I
know this is very immature and this is,
this is super fucking mean. And that is
an adult. I shouldn't tell you to do this.
Cause adults go with those people.
They're not your real friends.
You don't need to stoop to their level
and they give you all this fucking air
quote, mature advice. But you know what?
That doesn't help you when you go
back into the shit the next day.
Tell a teacher, none of that
shit fucking works, all right?
Because those fucking evil fucking
concert with terrible parents are going to
find the time they're going to find you.
So that's what I would do,
all right? There's no way. One of them
doesn't have a slightly crooked nose.
There's no way one of them's tiddy is
a little bit bigger than the other,
or maybe their nipples point down this
something fucked up about their chin.
If you know,
if you got to fight fire with fire,
if they're talking about you fucking
shoulders, all right? First of all,
laugh at it. Learned to laugh at
yourself. All right, let's look at me.
I'm an old freckled bald,
redheaded count, okay?
And all of those things should really
end any dream that I ever had in life.
But if you just roll with it,
if you steer into it,
and if I just be an old bald,
redheaded con,
then then what can you do to me
each just, you got to get comfortable. I
would get more comfortable with yourself.
All right. And uh, I'm sure your
shoulders are fine and all of that stuff.
And when they make fun of your shoulders,
laugh, and then I would say, yeah,
my shoulders are as fucked up as your
crooked Teddy's or just you somehow you
laugh at your shit and then you fucking,
you get them.
They get them. Just tell them you
just go. Do you once, you know,
just tell them they got bad breath.
You got any, I don't just, you'll find,
I wish you know what you could have if
he just could have sent me a picture of
him,
I would have helped you out.
But then I would've gotten in trouble
because you're teaching them to bully but
bad, blah, blah, blah. You know,
all of these people who want to,
who want to fix problems with five minutes
on fucking doctor Phil, by the way,
did I call it?
You see that big scandal over there
and that granted innocent until proven
guilty.
All doctor Phil fucking bringing
the guests up a notch there.
All right. I punched a girl. Whoa.
Here's another one. Hey Bill.
Like your input on a
situation. Uh, I was recently,
I was recently at a concert,
some drunk skank accused me of
stealing her friend's phone.
Uh, I told her you got the
wrong guy, her and her fuck her.
And her father friend tried to wrestle
my phone away from me and I pushed him
off. Then she sucker punched me in
the eye, big bruise, bloody eye.
And her friend snatched my phone out
of my pocket due to work that came up.
And I told them what happened.
He didn't seem to believe and was
clearly buddy buddy with the girls.
So they go off and we're giggling around,
giggling around.
I don't want the out.
That means after a few
minutes I go up to a,
to a Fatso.
Oh,
I go up to Fatso and tell
her to give me my phone back.
She realized it was
mine and handed it over.
As I went to walk away scag
number one introduce bag,
boyfriend accosted me
again and grabbed me.
I punched both them in the face
and then security escorted me out.
I think I was justified to
hit her in this case. What?
Say you then go fuck yourself.
Uh, yeah, I see. I see.
I don't have a problem with any of that.
I don't have a problem.
Someone gets physical with you.
You know,
you take one punch to the a year
over year, physically fucked up.
He didn't do anything wrong. Some point
you got to defend yourself. All right.
God bless you.
I think he showed remarkable
restraint to only hit him both ones.
That was an easy one. I wouldn't even,
I wouldn't even concerned about it.
Not at all. And in fact, you probably made
both of them better people. Hopefully.
Probably not. But you know, if I will, you
know, when you get punched in the face,
you know,
if you're an adult,
at some point you gotta be looking
at yourself going like, all right,
did I do something there? If you
didn't, then you're like, all right,
this person's an asshole and I need to
have them out of my life. But you know,
if you did, you got to be that guy and I
was kind of shooting my mouth off there.
Right? That's what I would do. Um,
all right, got two girls pregnant
help. Uh, dude, I can't help you.
There's no help for this. Uh, I buckled
down for the next fucking 18 years.
All right.
Hello Bill.
I have a big problem and I'm hoping
that you and the lovely Nia can help out
with it.
All right,
let me start by saying that I don't live
in a trailer is something I'm a normal
26 year old guy.
I was dating this girl and we broke up
a couple of months ago when we broke up.
A couple of weeks later,
I met this little Hottie,
I started hooking up with her and then
I got a call a couple of weeks ago.
My Ex is three months pregnant
with my child and she's keeping it.
Okay.
I then broke things off with
the hottie. Well, guess what?
I knocked her up to buddy.
Did you ever take a health class?
Do you know how to fucking
tell people get pregnant?
Neither one knows the other is pregnant
then I have no idea what to do.
I broke things off with the Hottie to
work on being there from my ex and the
kid.
I want to be there for her and help
her out with all the prenatal stuff.
It'd be a great dad. Now it sees my
life is not going to be that way.
The other girl wants to have the baby too.
I use protection with this girl,
but not enough, I guess.
What does that mean, dude?
If you use a condom, I would get
a maternity. Uh, first of all,
I would make both of them subject to it.
Okay.
Because you broke up for
a couple of months, right?
Get a maternity test times to do not
give either one of them a fucking dime or
else, you know, in some states, the second
you start paying, that kid is yours.
That's the first thing I would do.
First thing I would do was tell
both of them your situation.
The second thing I would get more,
make more both of them get a fuck,
isn't a maternity test. A paternity
test. I said maternity, paternity tests.
They go, oh, Jesus, uh,
the other girl wants to have
the baby to blah, blah, blah.
My ex was on birth control
yet I still knocked her up.
If I had to be with one of them, it would
be the new girl because she is harder.
I'm a pig Sumi and we also
like a lot of the same things.
What should I do? I'm so sick in an
exhausted of worrying about this.
I just want to do the right things.
Thank you. And Go fuck yourself. Well,
I would tell both of them what's going on.
I would get a paternity test,
not a maternity tests.
Get a paternity test and make
sure those are your kids.
And I would, if you want to be with
the Hottie, be with the hottie.
There you go. And then I would
stay in the life for the other one.
That's what I would dope.
And I would fucking get a vasectomy or
cut up a garden hose because whatever the
fuck you're using is not working.
All right. That's the podcast.
Oh, it's a long, one hour and 20 minutes
here. A happy new year to everybody.
Uh, good luck, Tia. Um,
I apologize to anybody.
The AA or whatever the fuck it is.
Um,
and that's it. I'm sipping my tea,
going to go eat healthy. All right.
And I will go back to booze at
some point if I fucking want to,
cause I don't think I have a
problem. All right, that's it. Uh,
I'll check in on you on Thursday.